mientras el tiempo vuela en la 26 las
naciones unidas- anticiparon un borrador
de su declaración final este miércoles
un documento que usarán los casi 200
países participantes para buscar acción
global consensuada en contra del cambio
climático entonces eso este es a menudo
el momento más difícil en un periodo de
dos semanas de la conferencia de las
partes de repente se reconoce que hay
una serie de cuestiones fundamentalmente
diferentes que no se pueden resolver
fácilmente tic tac el final de la coppa
está a la vista hop presence side el
texto insta a los países a impulsar sus
objetivos de reducción de emisiones para
2022 tres años antes de lo previsto
luego que los datos mostraran que el
mundo está muy lejos de limitar el
calentamiento a 15 grados celsius para
los críticos el camino es incierto o
viajar expreso esperábamos que los
países tendrían que regresar todos los
años para cerrar la brecha hasta que
estemos seguros de que nos mantendremos
por debajo de 1,5 grados este es un
texto bastante débil
a un punto de conflicto es el
financiamiento para los países en
desarrollo afectados por la
contaminación los países pobres dicen
que las naciones ricas se resisten a
comprometerse a pagar los daños que
causaron los objetivos en torno a los
subsidios al carbón y los combustibles
fósiles también se consideran débiles de
orissa reference sólo hay una referencia
a la eliminación gradual del carbón y
creemos firmemente que esa eliminación
gradual también merece una fecha límite
el shoá deadline en general los
delegados describieron el borrador de la
declaración como un buen comienzo pero
aún no lo suficientemente bueno para
evitar el debate climático